um we are hearing from people
via discord at davidpakman.com discord
let's go to lives in salt lake city uh i
don't know that we
get too many callers from utah liz tell
me what's going on there
and you please do set you to do not
disturb i'm already before even hearing
you
hearing your discord bleeping and
blapping so please set that to do not
disturb and i would love to hear from
you
hey david hello hey um so i'm calling in
from salt lake and
i was just curious what are the chances
that donald trump and his family
will be prosecuted after leaving office
i think it's very low
i i do believe that there's a good
chance
that there's going to be all sorts of uh
investigation
and maybe even settlements or fines for
donald trump's businesses
i really don't see criminal charges
coming
for the trump family it's not the way
this country has operated
i'm not saying it shouldn't i'm just
saying i don't
expect it to happen okay
um and i've got one more question for
you um what are the chances that uh don
jr is going to run for office in the
future and
you know what state do you think will
accept him and make that a reality an
unfortunate reality that he might run in
the future
well what do you mean what state will
accept him
like uh where does he have a chance of
running will he get like a second home
and become a resident of like
alabama or something oh you're saying
he's you're but would he be running for
president or for senate
senate maybe like governor working his
way to
the white house he seems ambitious
especially
oh he does his speeches and how he
supports his dad so i was just curious
like who will accept him and
do you think he has a future in politics
i don't see it but i
you know i think he's pretty
self-serving and i think at this point
we would be naive to say he has no
future and in fact when
i talk about the importance of removing
trump now
if we don't i think that 2024
much more naturally leads to a trump kid
running for something
and so as as much as it is important to
vote trump out now
for the sake of the world it's important
to vote trump out now
to not allow one of the kids an easier
path in 2024. i think that
if it listen if the republican party
voted for trump in the republican
primary
they would potentially vote for don jr
as well and we've got to make sure we
don't we don't
make that any easier for them
hello okay all right liz is gone i guess
so very very good
important question very very important
question
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an
entire book on your way home from work
they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one
into text or audio that you can get
through in just 15 minutes and you get
all of the
important core ideas and information
from that book
it's perfect if you don't have enough
time to do all the reading you want to
do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a when you go to blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video